If we want to divide by zero, we need to find its multiplicative inverse,...
...which should be one over zero.
This would have to be such a number that multiplying it by zero would give one.
But because anything multiplied by zero is still zero,...
...such a number is impossible.
So, zero has no multiplicative inverse.
Couldn't we make up a new rule?
Say, that the symbol infinity means one over zero and see what happens?
Let's try it,...
...imagining we don't know anything about infinity already.
Based on the definition of a multiplicative inverse,....
...zero times infinity must be equals to one.
That means zero times infinity plus zero times infinity should be equal two.
Now, by the distributive property,...
...the left side of the equation can be rearranged...
...to zero plus zero times infinity.
And since zero plus zero is definitely zero,...
...that reduces down to zero times infinity.
Unfortunately, we've already defined this as equal to one,...
...while the other side of the equation...
...is still telling us it's equal to two.
So, one equals two.
Oddly enough, that's not necessarily wrong;...
...it's just not true in our normal world of numbers.
There's still a way it could be mathematically valid,...
...if one, two, and every other number were equal to zero.
But having infinity equal to zero...
...is ultimately not all that useful to mathematicians or anyone else.